oh good evening I am Henry brink I'm a
senior at Hillsdale College I'm an
English major and I most recently from
st. Paul Minnesota and it is my pleasure
to introduce mr. Nathaniel Philbrick
this evening Nathaniel Philbrick is an
author and a research fellow at the
Nantucket Historical Association he
earned his BA from Brown University and
his MA from Duke University mr.
Philbrook is the recipient of numerous
awards including the Samuel Elliot
Morrison award from the USS Constitution
Museum the William Bradford award from
the pilgrim Society and a Lifetime
Achievement Award from the New England
historic Genealogical Society
he's the author author of numerous books
including in the heart of the sea which
won a national a National Book Award for
nonfiction and was the basis of the 2015
movie of the same name The Last Stand
Custer Sitting Bull and the Battle of
Little Bighorn and most recently in the
Hurricanes I the genius of George
Washington and the victory at Yorktown
so would you please help me in welcoming
mr. Nathaniel Philbrick
well thank you it is a great delight to
be here last time I was here I was
speaking about George Armstrong Custer
so we're now going to change venues a
little bit and go with George Washington
and I have to say it was after finishing
the last stand my book about Custer that
I was searching for topics and you know
most of my books tend to focus on
communities of people whether it's the
20 crew members of the whaleship Essex
that have just been rammed by a whale
and thrown into a survival situation or
102 pilgrims about to find themselves on
a coast about which they know nothing
and in the fall of 16 20 or Custer's
regiment bound for the Little Bighorn
where there is a Lakota village of
unimaginable size I'm interested in what
happens to communities under terrific
stress and I live on Nantucket Island
it's a community with a year-round
population of about 15,000 and our
daughter when she was I was a
stay-at-home dad growing up and we lit
briefly in historic Boston the historic
core which is the North End and I
remember pushing the stroller through
the North End of Boston imagining what
Boston was like in the time of the
revolution and Boston now looks entirely
different from what it did then back
then it was a 1.1 Square Mile Island
dominated by three hills of almost
mountainous size connect with a
population of 15,000 connected by a thin
neck of land to the mainland at Roxbury
and I began to think after moving to
Nantucket 15,000 you know I know what
it's like to live in a community of
15,000 you you go to the grocery store
you don't know everyone's by name but
you recognize them it's a personal way
you when you get to a stop sign and
someone blows you off you don't say
anything because that could be your your
kids teacher or your dental hygienist
which is really you don't want to anyway
so it's it's a it's a personal way of
looking at things and
so what would what would have been like
to be in Boston as the pressures of a
revolution mounted and so that led to my
writing Bunker Hill and that battle is
the obvious sort of plot point that
everything leads to but I found myself
unexpectedly taken with the gentleman
who arrives just a few weeks later
George Washington
now I had grown up with George
Washington like all of us do with George
staring at me from the $1 bill and you
know this is the guy of a statue
you know I at that point thought you
know what could be more boring than
George Washington but the George
Washington I was introduced to in Boston
in the summer of 1775 was anything but
boring
and very different from what he would
become the the the defensive-minded
general that would hold the nation
together
he was wild-eyed he was a lot like
George Custer this was George in his
early 40s red-haired he didn't like the
New Englanders he had inherited in the
provincial army you know New England has
a tradition we have it on Nantucket the
tradition of the town meeting and this
is democracy at its bare-knuckle best
where you know you you have a town
meeting and you basically fight it out
on the town floor and somehow you come
to a decision so these were people these
were young men who had grown up in these
kinds of situations where they always
had a say in what the was happening to
them so when Washington would deliver
them an order they would say whoa wait a
minute if we decide we want to do this
we will be very happy to fulfill your
order and this just drove Washington
crazy was used to a hierarchical society
and so Washington saw this group of
militiamen and just wanted to get it
over with here the British were in
Boston they were besieged by the
provincial army and this was a group of
professional soldiers he had these
militiamen no money no not enough
gunpowder he there was no way he could
see fighting along
or he wanted to get it over with he
wanted to attack Boston take it by storm
burn it down if necessary and just get
this thing over with three times he
would bring that proposal to his council
of war three times it would be voted
down unanimously and ultimately they
would go with a much more conservative
plan of bringing his his young
soon-to-be head of artillery Henry Knox
the bookseller who had learned
everything he knew about the military
through those books god bless
booksellers and would bring down the
cannons from Fort Ticonderoga that a few
of them would then end up on Dorchester
Heights giving them a commanding view
over Boston and General Howe who was
then the head of the lead leading the
British Army realized we got to get out
of here and thus would come the
evacuation of Boston in march of that
year and I just had to I had to follow
George I what was going to how would he
become the Washington who would be
capable of holding the country together
through eight years of war and
establishing the presidency
how would he so I that led me to my next
book about the revolution valiant
ambition in which I paired Washington
with Benedict Arnold we have people of
different arcs the book begins in summer
of 1776 by now the the British have left
Boston but the Empire is about to strike
back and it's New York which is in their
sights and a huge fleet arrives and at
in New York ultimately 40,000 soldiers
and sailors in a fleet of 400 vessels
this is more people than in all of
Philadelphia the largest urban center in
North America at that time and there is
Washington dug into New York and the
high ground in Brooklyn he's completely
out general in what will be called the
Battle of Long Island but what he is
brilliant at is is retreats which he'll
be doing a lot of in the
years ahead the nighttime retreat across
the East River is is one of the more
amazing logistical feats in which he
delivers his army to the island of
Manhattan under the noses of the British
cooler completely unaware that this is
happening he then is forced to retreat
all the way to to ultimately across New
Jersey to the Pennsylvania side of the
Delaware and it's really bad he's lost
most of his army to desertion and then
will come the the famous Battle of
Trenton in which he turns it round on
Christmas Day and which is an incredible
feat and and it's Washington at his best
it's Washington at the lowest but what
Washington had an ability to do is
Washington had an ax he would I speak of
him he had a true genius he wasn't a
genius like let's say founding fathers
Thomas Jefferson and in Hamilton he was
not a jittery brilliant person eloquent
and and a mind that could go anywhere he
had the ability to dial out the static
of life and believe me as Washington
retreated across New Jersey to the other
side of the Delaware River there was a
lot of static out there a lot of people
a lot of naysayers you know he had the
ability to assist say okay what is the
most important thing for me to do now
and so there in the Delaware he realized
we've got it we've got to have some kind
of comeback strategy here if we're gonna
do it we have to shock them it's the
only way we can turn this around he
succeeds in doing that it's one of the
most amazing comebacks in military
history
but it all you know but what I began to
realize with Washington his genius was
also and primarily so political he was
very good at working with others
listening to different sides subtly
moving people in directions that from
his point of view were the right way to
go and and when it came to fighting this
revolution he had to deal with Congress
this was you know we were creating
a republic and the great danger when it
came to revolutions in republics that
all of them would end with a military
coup the civil government in the wake of
a revolution is inefficient frustrating
the military whether it's Caesar whether
its Cromwell in England or in the future
Napoleon someone takes control and the
dream ends and this is what Continental
Congress was fearful of so they kept
Washington on a very tight leash and one
of the paradoxes is that the more
successful Washington God the more
untrustworthy congressmen became
particularly those in the south where
the excuse me those in New England where
the revolution had begun and then
following year would come the the Battle
of Saratoga in which largely through the
heroics of Benedict Arnold America would
score a great victory with Horatio Gates
as the commanding officer meanwhile
Washington lost a series of battles the
Battle of Brandywine and Germantown
allowing great the British William Howe
to to move into Philadelphia this got
the the politicians to wondering whether
Washington was the right person his army
is dug into - a Valley Forge that
terrible winter and there is an attempt
to replace Washington with Horatio Gates
it's unsuccessful largely because of
Washington's political brilliance he you
know he was one of these people he was
not necessarily the greatest military
strategist in the world but he was
terrific at working with people at
seeing the big side of things and his
his integrity was never never doubted he
succeeds in getting through that
terrible winter at Valley Forge and from
then on particularly with a stellar
performance the Battle of Monmouth he's
in it's you know he is the unquestioned
face of not only the Continental Army
but he is becoming the
of America and absolutely essential to
all this one of his best generals
Benedict Donald moves in in the other
direction he is denied a promotion by
the Continental Congress which were the
ones doling out the the promotions to
Major General he ultimately decides that
it while Washington's destiny to hold
the country together it's his destiny to
try to tear that country apart and he
unsuccessfully attempts to surrender
West Point where there are 3,000
soldiers and all sorts of armaments and
ammunition he unsuccessfully he attempts
to surrender that to the British that
happens in the late summer of 1788 is
foiled but America is at an absolute low
point you know we Americans went into
this revolution because we did not want
to pay taxes to Great Britain we
apparently did not want to pay the taxes
required to support Washington's army
it was withering on the vine recruitment
levels in the states were miserable
there just was nothing going on but
there was good news in 1778 after that
great victory at Saratoga France had
decided to enter the revolution on our
side and this is terrific
because France had what the American
army did not have an effective Navy up
until this point Great Britain its Navy
the most powerful in the world had a
stranglehold on the on the eastern
seaboard they could move troops at will
by sea with relatively lightning speed
enabling them to take Charleston to move
up and down Washington knew the only way
that they had a shot at a victory that
would potentially end this thing in a
favorable way was with the help of the
French Navy now previously France had
been humiliated by the British in the
Seven Years War or the French and Indian
War they had lost Canada their allies
Spain had lost Florida New Orlean
and but after that France had launched
into a program that they called Rivage
revenge and they realized how are we
going to regain the status we had before
the Seven Years War and that was by
retooling their Navy they created a
naval academy at breast which still
exists professor there was hugely
helpful to me in writing my book in the
hurricanes I they they they analyzed
naval warfare analytically applying the
ideals of that time to to analyze what
was going on and came up with tactical
guides that were way beyond anything the
British had in fact the British were
using those guys to help develop their
own tactics they it was they also were
retooling their Navy building better
ships than the British had by this time
it had been developed that the best ship
of the line and these a shipper though
it was called a ship of the line because
the way to to fleets would attack each
other was they create a line of battle
and the two fleets would come to within
firing distance sometimes only a pistol
shot away and blast away at each other
until one side began to gave give way
and it was realized at a 74 this is a
ship with 74 guns was the optimal size
for a ship of the line and these were
you know I think we have a tendency to
think of of square-rigged ships as kind
of quaint forms of transportation from
the past but a 74 was the most
sophisticated technological creation of
the 18th century between 500 and 750 men
aboard it took 2,000 oak trees to build
one that's 73 acres of forest if one of
these sailed into a harbor on the
American coast they would take over
because they had as many cannons as
Washington's army at the beginning of
the of the army and so Washington needed
the French French Navy and this is where
his genius comes in as soon as France
he realized what he needed more than
anything else was for France to
establish naval superiority somewhere on
the Atlantic coast where he could
coordinate with his army and win that
victory that would end the war but he
quickly realized this was going to be
difficult because what had happened with
the entry of France and then their
allies Spain was that a colonial
rebellion became a world war
now you had England fighting France and
Spain the war moved on into in as far as
India and the but the real center of
wealth in the world at this time was the
Caribbean the sugar islands of the West
Indies Jamaica what French Haiti for the
Spaniards it was Cuba you know most of
their income was coming from these
islands and so once France and Spain
enter the war they're French the ships
come in but they all go down to the
Caribbean and fight it out trading
islands back and forth much the
frustration of Washington who's stuck
outside New York we're now General Sir
Henry Clinton is dug in with 10,000
soldiers Washington is on the Hudson
sort of glaring at him for two years the
war has basically turned in the
Northeast has turned into a stalemate
Washington complains in a letter this
war drags on like a cart with no wheels
what what is positively happening is
happening what is happening is in the
south and it's not good for America the
the British take Charleston and then
Lord Cornwallis meets the the the hero
of Saratoga Horatio gates at Camden
South Carolina and Horatio gates is
completely annihilated he literally runs
from the battlefield and the American
army is scattered Washington decides to
send the the general who has become
really his most trustworthy general
Nathanael Greene a quoit raised a Quaker
in Rhode Island on Nantucket we love our
Quakers with a vengeance
and green would make his way south so
that was happening but what Washington
desperately wanted was finally to get
something happening with the Navy and
then in the fall of 1780 this is almost
a year precisely before it would be the
victory at Yorktown something happens in
the Caribbean three hurricanes in the
span of a month the first hurricane
would destroy much of Cuba and Jamaica
and and a good portion of the fleet's of
both of France and England and along
with Spain but it would be the the
second hurricane is now known as the
great storm of 1780 winds that are that
have been estimated had to be 200 miles
an hour
because what happened was the trees on
these aiya these islands were power
washed of their bark
you know just stripped every structure
annihilated 22,000 people would die in
the Caribbean in that one storm and then
just a few weeks later as the Spanish
Navy is a has just departed Cuba with a
5,000 soldiers a fleet of 40 ships
what's known as Solano's hurricane hit
sweats the Admiral in charge of the
Spanish fleet wipes out that fleet that
is fort and the wreckage is forced to
flee back to Cuba before they can attack
Spanish British held Pensacola because
that's Spain's real goal and then this
is the message that gets delivered to
France for the first time they realize
next summer and fall we don't want to
leave our fleet in the Caribbean we've
got to move them north we have to do as
Washington's requesting and come north
this is the beginning of the year of
Yorktown and it starts with a hurricane
next thing that happens is Benedict
Donald Britain's newest bet Brigadier
General is sent by Clinton to the
Chesapeake Benedict Arnold quickly
proves he might be the best general on
both sides
he speeds up the James River soon has
the the wartime capital of Richmond
which had been moved it that far inland
under the the the assumption that it
would be too far away for an enemy to
attack
Benedict Arnold strikes with lightning
speed governor Thomas Jefferson is
Jefferson is forced to flee it's in
flames well this obviously angers
Washington who sends down the young
French general who's become a kind of
surrogate son Lafayette to do battle as
best he can with Benedict Arnold the
meantime Nathaniel Greene has been doing
everything he can to consolidate his
army and he and Lord Cornwallis have it
out after what's known as the race to
the Dan across the the breadth of North
Carolina well at that point Greene
doesn't have the soldiers to face the
two thousand crack troops under Lord
Cornwallis he gets over the Virginia
border is able to swell his army with
militiamen dives back south and they
they they meet in the battle of guilford
courthouse Greene does not win because
Lord Cornwallis has the field at the end
but he has eviscerated Cornwallis's army
that's lost half their best Seoul
officers and men Cornwallis retreats to
Wilmington to refit retool but being
someone who is aggressive he decides
rather than retreat to Charleston and
consolidate the forces that in South
Carolina to move into Virginia where he
replaces Benedict Donald and he and
Lafayette battle it out in a fascinating
cat-and-mouse game meanwhile Washington
is in talks with French General
Rochambeau who is stationed in Newport
with with three five thousand soldiers
Washington is desperate for news about
where is the French Navy are you going
to help me
unfortunately Rochambeau has been
instructed by France not to inform why
of the whereabouts of the French Navy
their fear is that the American war
effort is about to collapse
they realized that recruitment levels
are not happening it looks like it's all
just gonna fall apart and in case that
happens the the fleet that leaves Brest
that winter under admiral de Grasse has
been instructed to then sail to newport
evacuate Rochambeau z' army and abandon
north america can you imagine if that
happened so they don't want Washington
to know quite where de Grasse is
Washington and Rochambeau have a meeting
in Wethersfield Connecticut to discuss
strategy Washington feels what they
should do is attack the British dug into
New York it's the only place where there
are enough soldiers where there could be
a victory big enough to end the war the
French however are fearful of entering
New York Harbor they like the Chesapeake
Rochambeau said tells George Washington
okay we'll do what you say because
Washington is the nominal head of the
Allied Force but secretly informs
Admiral de Grasse who by this time has
has left breast and as in the Caribbean
that if you when you come north you
should go to the Chesapeake it's not
until June that Washington reads in the
newspaper of de grasses activities in
the West Indies he confronts the group
he confronts Rochambeau so what's going
on here oh yes I took we've been in
talking don't worry things will work out
it's August 14th when Washington by this
time Roe shambo's Army has moved from
Newport to New York
combined with Washington's army on the
Hudson Washington gets a letter from De
Grasse informing him that De Grasse is
sailing not for New York as was thought
was agreed upon but for the Chesapeake
there's two congressional delegates who
are there with Washington when he gets
this letter apparently he was very angry
they go to prepare for breakfast they
meet up with him for breakfast
and he's completely calm down and this
is Washington he you know today we try
to fulfill our destinies as a
personality you know what is our inner
core let's become that Washington knew
his inner core his inner core was that
of someone with anger management issues
and he spent his whole life trying to
control that anger management you know
he very famously
studied the rules of civility he was
constant he was under incredible amounts
of caen self-control but every now and
then he just couldn't take it anymore
he would vent it but then always subsume
those emotions to do the best thing for
his country he calms down and he says to
the congressional delegates well the
plan has changed we are now going to
march from New York 500 miles to wait to
to Williamsburg and his New Englanders
do not want to march in August into the
killing heat of the south he says we're
gonna need help do your best to help us
and then this is Washington at his best
he's in a situation he didn't want to be
in but he's going to do the best to make
it work and this is where he enlisted
the same skills he showed during that
retreat across the East River he does an
amazing job of fooling Jenna general
Clinton in New York convincing him that
the aren't the the Allied forces are not
going to are going to attack New York
via Staten Island the letters are leaked
are supposedly stolen that you know
Clinton gets that that reinforce all
this Washington's not even telling
Rochambeau everything he's he's thinking
of doing because he knows secrecy is
paramount they begin to March the
soldiers and by this time one of the
reasons Washington did not want to
attack the Chesapeake was that Lord
Cornwallis was moving around the the
Virginia he wasn't staying in any one
place and if a large allied force moved
down there he would just move into South
Carolina and escape and in August that's
what they all assumed what Cornwallis
would do once they start it became
obvious that they were headed down he'd
just movin to North Carolina and
eventually South Carolina and they would
he would escape but for reasons that are
still not clear by this time Cornwallis
is dug into a town at the end of the
point formed by the James and York
rivers Yorktown he's digging in to form
a potential naval base suddenly he's got
there he is 7000 British and German
soldiers that's a big army things are
beginning to fall into place as
Washington would later write it was and
hit him like a ray of light if I can get
this army down there in time we just
might pull it off but he had to get the
French Navy there he had to get de
Grasse they Lee they they crossed the
Hudson all the time thinking Clinton is
going to tack them Clinton's convinced
they're going to attack them via Staten
Island they marched towards Staten
Island and then they veer to the south
and head for Philadelphia as fast as
they can there in Philadelphia when
Clinton realizes whoa they're not going
after me they're going after Cornwallis
Washington is has still heard no news
from de Grasse where is he by this time
he should be in the Chesapeake he's is
he's made his way to Elkton ahead of ELQ
they called it at the northern tip of
the Chesapeake where they're going to
begin transporting a good portion of the
two armies by boats down the Chesapeake
towards towards Yorktown he still hurt
has heard nothing from de Grasse a
messenger approaches with with an
express de Grasse has sailed into the
Chesapeake with 28 ships of the line
it's happened this has happened that
it's it's there
Washington is so estatic he turns his
horse around rides as fast as he can to
Chester Pennsylvania
if you go there now there's a gambling
casino that's where William Penn first
stopped when on his arrival to what
would become Pennsylvania but and
because he knows Roth Shambo and his
entourage has been sailing down the the
Delaware inspecting forts along the way
they they're the the French are
approaching the dock at Chester and they
see someone the tall man in in
regimentals with a hat in one hand a
handkerchief and the other jumping up
and down and going like this and they
say who could that be you know who
couldn't be Washington he'd never do
anything it's George Washington he is so
excited that finally this this plan that
no one could have ever really put
together is happening Rochambeau
disembarks they hug in Washington was
not a hugger they move on it's now a
race we've got to get down there as
quickly as possible they make it to
Mount Vernon Washington has not been
home in six years four grandchildren
have been born
while he's been away can you imagine the
emotions of that they spread out the the
maps on the dining room table strategize
they leave their their their just a
little ways down the road when
Washington gets another message a large
British naval force has just approached
the Chesapeake the French have sailed
out this was four days ago and nothing
has been heard from them since now in
the history of naval warfare if two
comparable fleets of French and British
met the British always won now I'm not
going to go into detail about the Battle
of the Chesapeake because that's why you
have to buy the book but I will say it
has been rightfully called the most
important naval battle in the history of
the world in terms of its ultimate
consequences because for the first and
last time that's an exaggeration
the French would win they would force
at Admiral graves to sail back to New
York for repairs deGrasse returns to the
Chesapeake just as Washington and
Rochambeau are arriving they meet under
grass's flagship as the armies come down
and the trap closes around Lord
Cornwallis who's been assured by Clinton
in New York that don't worry we're going
to save you thus begins the siege of
Yorktown a the the French have this act
this is Roe shambo's 17th siege I mean
this these were very common in European
warfare and so the French are very good
at this and it's it's it's mid-october
when Lord Cornwallis is forced to
surrender
thus delivering the victory that
Washington had foreseen in his quest for
naval superiority now so many times in
working with on this book and studying
Washington I wanted there to be the time
where he could go yes you know I finally
did it but within days of this great
victory his his stepson Jacky Custis
would die of camp fever
this meant that as the country was
celebrating he and Martha were in Mount
Vernon in mourning they would eventually
make their way to Philadelphia and then
back to the outskirts of New York it
would take two and a half years to
negotiate the treaty that would finally
end this war and it was really in the
the spring of 1783 that Washington would
meet his greatest challenge I think as
general and it would not be in warfare
by this time his his army was in
Newburgh New York the men the men hadn't
been paid for four years his officer up
until then there had been mutinies but
the officers had always been in line
with Washington and controlled things
now the officers were the ones that
wanted some assurance that they would be
compensated for sacrificing their lives
for all
this time but what you know we barely
had a government the Continental
Congress was a government in name only a
window dressing of a government they
didn't have the ability to tax the
American people directly you know
there's just wasn't going wasn't going
to happen
the officers put together a proposal
that if that they should march on
Philadelphia and demand that the
Continental Congress fulfill their
wishes this would have been the military
coup that would have destroyed the
Republican experiment of the United
States Washington calls his men together
and delivers a speech to his officers
they listen to it and are unmoved by
this time Washington's just turned 50
and like many people turning 50 he's
beginning to have trouble reading and
he's just gotten his first pair of
reading glasses but no one has seen him
wearing them he delivers the speech no
one's excited about it and then he says
well I want to read this letter from a
congressional delegate that is
sympathetic to your cause he takes out
the letter and clearly he's having
trouble to read and then he says excuse
me I have not only gone gray in the
service of my country I am going blind
he puts on those glasses and begins to
read and there is not a dry eye in the
house he leaves soon after the men
unanimously agree to do whatever George
Washington wants them to do Washington
saved America in that instance finally
in in November of 1783
the British evacuate New York Washington
has determined that he will surrender
his military commission to Congress when
George the third hears that this is
Washington's intention he says that he
if Washington does that he will be the
greatest man in the world and that's
what Washington did he had to go to
Annapolis because Congress had moved
from Philadelphia to a nap
because they were fearful their own army
was going to attack them so they had
moved to Annapolis it just shows you at
me and then it took them two weeks to
get a quorum before Washington could
surrender his commission he does that he
he was so overwhelmed with emotion that
he had to hold his rut shaking right
hand with his left while he delivered
his speech he then made his way to Mount
Vernon and arrived at Mount Vernon on
Christmas Eve 17 383 now I finished in
the Hurricanes I on Christmas Eve it was
a very different kind of Christmas for
me and I have to tell you you know I
grew up thinking that the American
Revolution was a series of battles
leading to a Nevitt of American victory
that it was there a series of stepping
stones it wasn't like that at all
by the the fall of 1780 every everything
was up in the air and as Washington
watched it was a series of seemingly
random events under no-one's specific
control that had to fall into place for
it all to work and as he would say in a
letter if you do not believe in God look
what happened for it to him in America
in that year and so I think the
hurricane is the appropriate metaphor
for this war and you know it was this
series of you know events circling
around that could have gone anywhere but
always there was Washington you know
holding it together in the Hurricanes I
thank you very much
[Applause]
thank you we now have time for Q&A
please make your way to the microphone
if you have a question also mr.
Philbrick will be signing a copy of his
book in the Hurricanes eye the genius of
George Washington in the victory at
Yorktown out in the Sorrell Center
directly following the lecture
thank you my wife says that I'm naughty
and I shouldn't ask this question but I
have children in the Naperville high
school or grandchildren in Naperville
Illinois and I went there to a meeting
some years ago where Howards End was the
speaker hardest now died and he says
that Washington and Jefferson are kin to
the devil and he's a communist he's
written the textbook that is the most
popular across the country that teaching
our kids I'm a member of the Chicago
presbytery
this is the parent body for all the
Presbyterian churches in the Chicago
area and they've completed they a study
on racism and they start out by saying
that Washington Jefferson all these
people were racists they're bad people
and that our big companies were founded
by racists and so our churches are
plagued with racism and so this has
passed the presbytery and all the
churches are now supposed to be dealing
with this terrible racism because of
Washington and so on help me what can
you say to this
[Laughter]
well you know I have to I think it's
important to look at you know the
founding fathers in terms of the slavery
issue and all of that and I think
Washington is a very important figure in
that yes he was a slave owner and and
but there was - he grew up as a slave
owner he you know he owned slaves even
before he was you know had the ability
as a kid this was what he grew up in
what is remarkable about Washington and
what I feel makes him the only person
who could who is deserving of the title
the father of our country is that it was
his experience in eight years as as as
commander of the Continental Army he
changed he recognized that it was much
more than Virginia you know he the New
Englanders he didn't like when he first
arrived in in Massachusetts became his
most trusted soldiers went by the time
it came to the March to Yorktown he you
know through Lafayette who is an
abolitionist he began to to recognize
the evil of slavery you know there were
two people inhabited and yet his life
was completely interwoven in that
institution and he during the war he
wanted as he said he wanted to get rid
of the institution but he was he had you
know many of his slaves were owned by
his wife Martha which made it illegal
for him to do anything so he was
embedded in all that what's remarkable
about washing I think it you've got to
look at people's ability to learn and
and to change and to see to see things
as they are and there is no one like
Washington where you see that arc in
which finally on his deathbed you know
he is dying of a throat infection in
which he is basically being strangled to
death I mean just a horrible way to go
he had just recently drafted a new will
in which he freed
slaves and you know there he is on the
bed and he asked Martha to bring the two
drafts two drafts of his will he has her
destroy the old one to keep the other
one and this is his dying Act which
established a precedent that was clearly
seen you know so you I think you have to
put people in the timeframe in which
they lived you know my book about in the
the the whaleship Essex I've had readers
who say I I could not have any sympathy
for whaler because they killed whales in
my response to that is if you grew up on
Nantucket in the nineteenth century you
would have you know if you had been a
boy you would have been a Whaler and if
you had been a woman you would have been
economically dependent on it
it's you know it's the context you've
got that we've got you've got to see
that and if you it's the it you know
it's it's really not fair to the past
and it's not fair to America I think
ultimately you have to look at this
country as we are now and what's great
about America is we were born in a
revolution and we will always be in the
midst of a revolution as our each
generation redefines the the
Constitution and the Declaration of
Independence in terms of its own time
it's it's it's messy its disruptive it's
not terribly efficient but it's what
keeps us a free nation and we you know
we're an aspirational people you know we
are always trying to be better and that
is the essence of America and we
wouldn't we wouldn't have this country
if it hadn't been for George Washington
I'm now working on a kind of different
kind of book I've spent the last two
years my wife and I and our dog Dora had
been following Washington's travels as
president when he became president you
know he realize I'm the head of 13
independent states you know what do I do
to create a sense of solidarity he went
on a road trip and he didn't do it in
Air Force One
he got into a carriage he had you know
two secretaries and six servants two of
them enslaved and they the first trip
was New York was the temporary capital
they went you know they they went to
sixty different towns in New England
just little towns he made the decision
that he was not going to stay in private
homes because that would be playing
favorites he stayed in taverns you know
taverns
in 1789 where the you know flea-bitten
Motel sixes of his day and and you know
that's what he did and it took him a
month to do this he went to every town
and people who were naysayers and
believe me there were naysayers saw him
saw his commitment to the the concept of
the government and you know and he
created that solidarity he would is the
longest tour would be three months down
to the south he was a southerner but you
know he had barely been to North
Carolina never south of that you know
went all the way down to Savannah to
Augusta and and back in and so we have
been following him by car and we just
cannot believe the stamina of this guy
the commitment of this guy you know
Washington slept here is kind of a
historical joke it's not a joke
I mean the amount of war he he slept in
two hundred eighty three different
places before the end of the Revolution
and then he did this kind the the guy
was out there you know trying to make
America work and if a we would not have
the freedoms we have today we would not
have the ability to have these kinds of
conversations if it hadn't been for
George Washington
well now I have two questions well now I
have two questions are you gonna include
I probably in one of those trips road
trips of his he visited like what two
synagogues and spoke to two Jewish
communities yeah so you should include
that in that oh yeah yeah know what it's
great he okay so he did the the New
England tour but Rhode Island and I went
to college in Rhode Island and you know
Rhode Islanders or Rhode Islanders and
with Roger Williams the the independent
man and they hadn't ratified the
Constitution by the time Washington went
on his New England tour so he very
carefully took there's there are three
ways to get north from New Haven you
know you could take where I 95 goes
along the coast which would go through
Rhode Island or you could take go the
inland route to Hartford Springfield and
then to Boston he went inland and never
went to Rhode Island that put a lot of
pressure on the state and that was
absolutely his intention and so within a
few months time they ratify the
Constitution that summer in 1790 and
this is when all sorts of stuff is
happening in his government
you know Jefferson has just become his
Secretary of State he and Hamilton are
you know they're uneasy relationship is
beginning they're trying to work out the
compromises that will you know create a
tax structure and all that and
Washington goes decides it's time to go
visit Rhode Island so he and Thomas
Jefferson get on one of John Brown's
packets and sail to Newport and there he
he got a letter from a member of the
Jewish congregation in in Newport one of
the oldest caught if there's a little
argument who's the oldest whether New
Yorker or Newport but this one was
really old and Washington's response
which Jefferson may have had a hand in
it because religious freedom was a big
part of where Jefferson came from in
which it is still looked to today as one
of the most eloquent expressions of the
importance of religious freedom ever
written and it was during
this this trip and so my wife and I
sailed to Newport to do this and had
just the most fantastic tour of the
synagogue and you know it's this is a
living history you know this it's it's
you know it's not a statue or a museum
exhibit with dust gathering around it
what Washington by going there
Washington kicked created a ripple
effect which these communities are still
feeling and you know I you know in a way
all history is local
you know Tip O'Neill used to say that
about politics but I and that's what's
been really fun following Washington on
this is I've contacted archivists
librarians each one all of these towns
and looking for records of the citizens
responses to Washington's and each just
about every one of these towns has a
plaque somewhere and then somewhere in
the middle of the 19th century someone's
great-grandmother you know who was about
90 had a memory of when Washington came
to town how was Admiral de Grasse
remembered in French history yeah well
Admiral de Grasse great hero from our
perspective unfortunately and Washington
and Rochambeau both complained about it
de Grasse was was a good Admiral but
very impulsive and did not always have
the best judgment within and he was
lucky he went up against a very mediocre
British Admiral it was nobody's first
choice to be meeting
de Grasse in this a few months later de
Grasse goes up against one of the
Britain's great Admirals Admiral Rodney
in the in the West Indies it's known as
the Battle of the Saints and the Grozny
a fleet would get completely routed by
Rodney degraaf's had the the biggest
flagship in all of the Navy's anywhere
he would be forced to to surrender his
sword to to to to Rodney it's just
absolutely humiliating you'd be a
prisoner in London for a number of
months and it was a huge embarrassment
to to France and so he has not looked
remembered fondly but the one thing was
good about that from as from my
standpoint as historian was that there
were court-martial proceedings following
that great defeat and as a consequence
the logbooks of many of the captains
that were at the Battle of the
Chesapeake were preserved and are still
at the archives in Paris and they were
an absolute treasure trove for me when
it came to recreating the Battle of the
Chesapeake because you know it's a past
accounts leaned very heavily on English
accounts I think largely because they're
in English the fact is the French
Academy there's a lot of them and so I
found the and I'm a sailor I grew up
sailing racing those great magnificent
yachts known as sunfish and I am a
sunfish North American champion that's
no laughing matter but but but as a
sailor it was so exciting to read these
logbooks and I worked with a translator
in Quebec who helped me with this to
read these accounts of of this battle
it's it's just a fascinating slugfest
and you know for me as a historian it's
that's the juice you know you're getting
those relat sources that haven't been
used that those primary sources that
speak to you as if they were speaking to
you today we have time for one more
question thank you
several years ago dr. D James Kennedy in
Florida spoke about George Washington
and he said that in modern times it's
been popular to denigrate or downplay
the importance of his Christian faith in
his life and in his decisions could use
and he
he went through quite a teaching on
showing the importance of his Christian
faith could you speak to that please
yeah yeah
Washington faith is a fascinating thing
you know I I think you know he and it
really ties into his role as a
battlefield commander too when he was
experienced the his early on when he was
representing Britain in the the French
and Indian War you know he was there at
Braddock's defeat where every officer on
horseback was killed or wounded except
for him and he had three bullet holes
through his uniform one through his hat
and his best friend and doctor dr. Craig
who would actually be there by his
bedside when he died talked to several
Indian warriors that were there and told
him how everyone was aiming at George
Washington and couldn't believe they
didn't kill him and he was they gave him
a name of the person who cannot be
killed or words that you know to that
effect and I think he you know that gave
him a profoundly spiritual sense of
mission you can see it in his letters
after that you know he you know he will
he worshiped in the Church of England
which became complicated after the
Revolution because you then had the
founding of Episcopalian faith and that
was a rough transition and it's
interesting after after the Revolution
he would cease taking communion he would
attend church every Sunday but you know
no one knows you know quite what was you
know had presiding over that many men
killed you know what was he thinking
about slave who knows what it was or
maybe he was just angry at the the what
was happening in terms of the new
Episcopalian Church who knows but
spirituality was absolutely important to
him
you you know you you it it's it's his
letters his his whole demeanor was was
highly spiritual you know but I think
also ultimately with Washington who is
an intensely private man for someone so
public it was ultimately you know his
own thing and from my mind I think that
I have all the more respect for him
because of that well thank you very much
thank you